hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
implementation of a multiplex molecular
test for anaplasma
babesia and erlichia i am jennifer woods
of labrus and i will be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab roots and brought to
you by deosorin molecular
to learn more visit
molecular.diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation i'd
like to now welcome our speaker
sarah bess clinical and molecular
microbiology director
northern light laboratory in bangor
maine
sarah you may now begin your
presentation
thank you jennifer and thank you for
inviting
me to speak um the only thing that i
would like to
disclose today is that
this talk is not about coded i think
we are all tired of covid that
said i think because of the impact
that kova did have on our lives both
inside and outside of the laboratory
we would be missing an opportunity if we
did not
address the effect that it had
on our testing program and on tick-borne
diseases in general
so i will be discussing that a little
bit
aside from that this talk is about
tick-borne disease and i think that's
why you're here
so we're going to focus on anaplasma
sabesia and erlichia i'm not going to
talk about lyme disease even though
that's an important
aspect of life here in the northeast
especially
i'm going to start by giving you a
little bit of background on each of the
organisms
and the diseases they cause and then i'm
going to give you a little bit of
background
about the problem of tick-borne disease
in my state
of maine and talk about how we detect
these organisms in my lab
so first up is anaplasma
so anaplasma phagocytophylum is a
bacteria that is transmitted by the
exody scapularis tick
on the east coast and the exode
specificistic
on the west coast the disease caused by
the organism is known as anaplasmosis
or sometimes human granulocytic
amnioplasmosis
as a nod to the fact that the organism
has a trophism for granulocytes
particularly neutrophils
symptoms of anaplasmosis tend to appear
about a week or two
after a tick bite and they really vary
in severity
they can be pretty mild or if untreated
they can they can get severe
the other thing about the symptoms that
is important is that they're
relatively non-specific things like
fever chills
body aches and sometimes gi symptoms
like nausea and vomiting
as i said when the disease goes
untreated
there can be more severe consequences
things like respiratory or organ failure
death is really rare the fatality rate
is less than one percent
which is good but it can happen
when a patient presents usually the
laboratory findings
come up with things like
thrombocytopenia leukopenia
or elevated liver enzymes and
in terms of a confirmatory diagnosis
there's a couple of different ways to go
about it
you can see anaplasma
micro colonies as morula in a blood
smear
however i don't think anybody would
suggest that this is a good way to
diagnose the organism and certainly it's
not a
confirmatory means of diagnosis
it's more like an incidental finding
when you see it
a finding that can point you in the
right direction
you know our technologists here in
hematology
are actually pretty good at picking out
the morela on a blood smear
and when they see that they can
sometimes use the type of cell they're
seeing it in
to point them in the direction of
anaplasma or lickia because the
organisms have different trophisms for
cell types
but what they really do is they ensure
that a pcr test
has been ordered so pcr
in the acute stages of infection anyway
is the most sensitive
and specific means for detecting
anaplasma
serology can be used but it is not
effective early on and there are
specificity issues with the methodology
the other thing about serology is it
requires paired acute inconvalescent
samples a few weeks apart
doxycycline is an effective treatment
for anaplasma
especially when it started early during
the course of infection
and treatment with doxy is actually
recommended for people of all ages
including
young children which can sometimes be
you know something that people don't
realize
so babisia is another organism
transmitted by exodus scapularis ticks
this is an ap complexion parasite and in
the united states
lebesia microtea is the most prevalent
species the disease it causes is called
the besiosus and again we have some
non-specific symptoms
like fever chills nausea and fatigue
but the parasite does actually destroy
red blood cells
and it can lead to a hemolytic anemia
associated with symptoms like jaundice
and dark urine
and i think due to this fact some
providers feel that clinically they can
distinguish disease caused by babies
from that caused by anaplasma
and or likia which is important will be
important in this talk later
when we talk about how we offered our
pcr test as a multiplex
or singleplex assay
laboratory findings associated with
babesia
include things like thrombocytopenia
anemia and elevated
liver enzymes and
diagnosis is similar to that of
anaplasma
but in this instance a game sustained
blood smear
can be a confirmatory means to diagnose
the parasite although of course it's not
as sensitive
as something like pcr which
i can show you what i mean more later on
in the talk with a couple of case
examples
in our lab we do offer blood smears for
babesia
and what i see is them being used most
often
to monitor the percent parasiteemia
in a patient when they know that patient
is positive
more commonly we're using pcr in our lab
because again it's sensitive and
specific
serology is like with anaplasma useful
later in the course of disease
so erlichia chaffiensis is actually
transmitted by
a different tick the lone star tick and
there are
other species of erlickia that can cause
a problem in humans
but they're not as widespread especially
geographically as they're looking at
chaffiantis so that tends to be the one
at least i think about the most often
the disease caused by erlichia species
is caused is called erlichiosis or human
monocytic or
likiosis and it has symptoms that are
really very similar to that of anaplasma
and a lot of other things because
they're they're fairly non-specific
symptoms and
if erlichiosis goes untreated it can
lead to more severe consequences
again similar to the other things that
we've been discussing things like
respiratory
or organ failure sometimes encephalitis
death remains low with this type of
infection but it is a possibility
the situation with diagnosing arlichia
is very similar to that of anaplasma
where
you can see morula in a blood smear as
more like an incidental finding
and pcr is a great way to detect the
organism
early on with serology
having a place maybe later in the course
of infection
so just a little bit of background about
my laboratory
northern light lab we are a reference
lab that
serves the hospitals in our health
system
the ten of which are indicated on this
map
and the star is eastern maine medical
center and that's where we are
physically located
about maybe 60 percent of our business
comes from
hospitals or providers that are outside
of our health care system
but either way most of the patients we
serve are geographically located
in mid and northern maine with a few
pockets in the portland area
i don't know how much everybody knows
about maine
but it is a beautiful state
these are two pictures that i took one
while we were hiking the precipice trail
in acadia national park
and the other my daughter hiking on a
trail near our house and i included
these pictures to illustrate a couple
things about our state
one being we are known as vacation land
we have
an abundance of outdoor opportunity and
i think a fact that i find surprising is
that maine has more coastline than the
state of california
and in general we're a very wet space we
have a lot of lakes we have a lot of
ponds and rivers and streams
the other thing we have a lot of is
forest lands
maine is actually the most forested
state
in the country and i think that's
important
when we're talking about ticks because
it must not be hard to imagine that a
wet
and forested state is a great habitat
for ticks and the tick-borne pathogens
that they harbor so because
ticks are such a problem in our state
the maine center for disease control and
prevention has a really great website
that has historical and what they call
near real-time data
related to lime and anaplasma
and babesia and what this represents
are the number of human cases reported
to
the state each year
for the various diseases and what i'd
like to point out is
maine has a relatively small population
about 1.3 million people but we see a
ton
of tourists each year the last date i
saw said something like 37 million
this doesn't have anything to do with
the tourists up here this is just people
who have
an address in the state of maine i have
no doubt that there's a lot of tourists
that visit maine and then return
home with some type of pig born illness
but what's interesting about this data a
couple things
you can see that we have more lime than
anaplasma
more anaplasma than babesia and you can
also see
that the rate of tick-borne disease
dropped off significantly
in 2020 was almost cut by half in 2020
and you know we have a little bit of
disease here in 2021 but we're still
we're we are just coming out of winter
believe it or not
um so when i saw this i was kind of
wondering why
the disease dropped off so significantly
in 2020
and you know the first thing you think
about is covet obviously
and oh maybe reduce travel um
but you know even though tourism was
reduced this doesn't represent the
number of
tourists that were getting sick this is
residents and residents were still here
we were still getting outside maybe even
more so than in the past we were still
doing the kinds of things that
would lead to tick-borne disease so
when i first saw it my first thought was
that the decline in disease was actually
related to a decline in the number of
ticks we saw
in 2020. so another really great
data source that we have access to is
from the university of maine's
cooperative extension program they have
a pick surveillance program
where you can send them a tick that you
found it doesn't have to be embedded it
just has to be you know found somewhere
within the state of maine
and for free they will identify that
tick
to the species level the life stage
level
and they'll notate whether it was
engorged or not
and then the tick will wind up as a dot
in their map
and so i summarized their data here and
what you can see is that they actually
received more ticks
in 2020 than in 2019.
there's a couple caveats with that
number one
this isn't them going out dragging for
ticks this is random manor sending in
ticks that they find
so it's really a matter of awareness to
a certain extent
the program was new in 2019 and 2020
more people probably knew about it
and frankly in 2020 people had nothing
better to do than submit ticks that they
found
on their property so i think that
probably artificially
inflated the number somewhat in 2020
the other thing that this data isn't
showing you
is the life stage of the tick
and that's a really important point
because they do have that data on their
website and what they
show is that while there were more adult
picks
submitted in 2020 than in 2019 there
were fewer nymphs
and we had a particularly hot and dry
spring and summer here in maine and that
led to
a decline in the population of nymphs
that we saw
and because mints are so small they can
go undetected
and they contribute significantly to the
spread of tick-borne disease
so i do think that the reduction in
nymphs
was a large part of the reason we saw a
decline in tick-borne disease
another thing i was able to look at is
whether the ticks that we saw
in maine in 2020 were less likely to be
carrying
a pathogen so the university of maine's
cooperative extension program
also has a service where they identify
the pathogens associated with the ticks
that are submitted
you can pay a small fee and they will
submit the
data back to you to be honest i'm not
sure if they test every tick they
receive
or just the ones where the people who
submitted it paid the fee but either way
i think it's really interesting data and
what you can see
is that first of all over 40 percent of
our ticks in both 2019 and 2020
were positive for more than one pathogen
i think that's really striking
you have a pretty high chance of
encountering a tick
that has at least one pathogen in it
when you're in the state of maine
and what else i think is important from
this data is that the numbers didn't
really go down that much
between 2019 and 2020. there was a small
reduction in just about everything
outside of um babesia in
in nymphs in 2020 but i don't think it
was significant enough to contribute to
that striking reduction in tick-borne
disease that we saw
so my assumption is that that reduction
was as we talked about
due to the reduction in nymphs but also
due
to a decline in office visits that was
coveted related you know people
were not visiting their providers as
much as they had in the past
they were probably preoccupied with
covid and if you think about it some of
the
non-specific symptoms of these diseases
overlap with that of covid
and even though anaplasma babesia
can cause symptoms
that are severe a lot of times there
they can be self-limiting infections
so my guess is that we had less less
nymphs
a little bit less disease but also more
undetected
disease in 2020
the only other thing that i want to show
you about the university of maine
extension program is that they were a
little bit better about achieving their
2020 goals than i was
they in 2019 said that they wanted to
expand
their deer tick panel to include
borrelia miami toy
i was really excited about that because
i have a feeling we see a lot more
of that organism in our state then we
realize a lot more disease caused by
that organism than we realize because we
aren't testing for it so i was
interested in that but they were unable
to achieve it
but what they did achieved was they put
a non-deer tick panel together
that included rickettsia or ketsi or
likia
and francisella tularensis
and what i think is interesting is you
can see there weren't very many lone
star ticks submitted to their program
but to the ticks that were submitted at
a
reasonably high percentage we're
carrying our likia
so erlichia is present in the state of
maine it's just that the ticks that
harbor it
are not very prevalent at this time
so the very last thing about this data
that i want to point out is
it is not recommended to test
ticks as a means to detect an infection
in humans
i i feel the need to say that um i still
think this data is
really very interesting and very
important from a surveillance
perspective
because these pathogens they show up in
the ticks before they show up in people
but that said it is definitely not
recommended
to test the tick as a means of
determining whether or not
you have an infection you know that tick
could harbor a pathogen that it was
not able to transmit to you in the time
that it was
attached or the pick that you found may
not have had a pathogen but the tick
that you didn't find that [ __ ] you
could have so i think it's important to
note that
but i still think the data is super
interesting in
in relevant
all right so just one more thing um
to point out our hospitals
overlay somewhat nicely with the
location of the ticks that were
submitted
to the university of maine's program so
i used to think that respective to our
eyes we got
a ton of requests for tick-borne disease
testing and specifically pcr
but covid really changed my perspective
on
testing volume in a major way and you
know even though i still think we get a
relatively large number of samples in
our door for tick-borne disease testing
that
obviously pales in comparison to the
number of samples we get in for coded
testing
all right so this is some historical
data
from my lab to kind of help illustrate
why we wanted to bring a test in-house
in 2018 through 2018
pcr testing for anaplasma babesia and
erlichia was available
as a send-out test in my lab
and i chose to show you guys june
through december here not because that's
our tick season but because we're going
to
look directly at 2019 data to compare it
to
so what you can see is that from june
through december
of 2018 we sent out 1465 what i'm going
to call tri-panel meaning
anaplasma the bezier enderlichia pcr
tests
and we saw about a three percent
positivity for anaplasma
and about a point three percent
positivity for babesia
during that same time we sent out
a smaller number 120 samples for
anaplasma and our likia pcr
with the positivity for anaplasma being
at about that same three percent rate
we saw no positives for likia in this
period
and then we sent out a small number 22
samples for babisia pcr only
and of those samples nine percent were
positive for babesia
and that higher number or higher
percentage
kind of lends credence to the fact that
providers can clinically
pick out when a patient might have
vebesia as opposed to some of these
other diseases
so during the period we also sent out
about 400 samples for anaplasma
and or babesia serology
and we in-house um performed 88
parasite uh blood smears and of those 88
23 were positive for babesia species but
i think it's important to show that
only three of those there was only three
patients represented in those three
23 positive smears our providers
really do like to follow the especially
sick
patients that have visia with blood
smears to get that percent parasiteemia
over time
so in looking at this data it's
important to understand that
just the molecular testing alone cost us
over half a million dollars to send out
in addition to that the turnaround time
was less than ideal
mostly i would say due to time in
transit remember we're a reference
laboratory ourselves
so clients have to get their samples to
us and then we would have to get it to a
reference laboratory to get this testing
done you know we were looking at three
four five day turnaround times here
which was less than ideal another
smaller issue that we had when we were
sending out this testing
was a relatively high number of patients
for which molecular testing was repeated
multiple times i would say
inappropriately repeated
and also some redundancy between
patients who had molecular testing and
serology ordered at the same time
and in our laboratory anyway it's harder
to control
you know cutting back on duplicate
testing when it's a send out
versus when it's done in-house for
whatever reason
so because of all that we really really
started to think about bringing this
test
in-house
so when we first started to think about
what the assay we would bring in would
look like pretty quickly we realized it
would have to be an ldt
because there were i would say there are
no commercially
available um fda cleared assays
available for detecting anaplasma or
lithia
or babesia good thing was our lab is not
against ldt's we do a few of them not a
ton but we have some experience in that
space and we weren't
afraid to go there
for the nucleic acid extraction piece
that was a relatively simple piece to
consider
we already owned a easymag
and we were already extracting from
blood
on that instrument using the off-board
lysis setup that they had
so this was something that we were very
comfortable and familiar with
the other piece was that at the time we
also had
three liaison mdx thermocyclers from
deosorin
and we were pretty comfortable with that
platform
i knew of the anaplasma of ibesia and
erlichia asrs that they had available
and i will say for a moment i did
consider other options
i had previously worked at a tick-borne
disease lab
in new york state and i knew the assets
that that lab used
were published and i had used them i was
comfortable with them as well
but really when i started thinking about
that
our lab doesn't have a standalone
real-time pcr
machine that lends itself to ordering
your own primers and probes and throwing
an assay together
and perhaps more importantly
we were not set up to clone and so when
i started thinking about an internal
control and putting one together
ourself that became you know somewhat
overwhelming
obviously cloning isn't that difficult
but when your lab is not set up to do it
when you're in a clinical lab that's
busy there really just isn't time
so pretty quickly we settled upon um
the dsorin assay we thought that was our
best bet
and we decided to move ahead with their
asrs and their
sample extraction and amplification
control
reagent as our internal control um
and we also used the asorn ta master mix
and the universal disc for this pcr
the universal disc is also something
that we had experience with from other
assays
that we had used over the years and i'll
talk a little bit about
that in just a bit
so i knew that we would need positive
samples
and i knew that we would need something
quantified in order to do
our lod studies and back when we were
working on this
exact diagnostics was not prepared to
offer control material for babesia i
think that took them a little while to
get
up and running with and i didn't want to
wait
for them they may have it now i'm sure
they do
but at the time i chose to move forward
by
ordering full-length synthetic jeans
from thermo fisher i ordered their gene
art
strings product that worked well for me
because
we knew which genes the dsr and asrs
targeted
but we didn't know what regions of the
genes they targeted
and these gene art strings they can be
made long enough
to cover the entire gene so
we kind of gathered all these components
to get together
and got ready to begin
a validation so
as you know there's a requirement before
you use any assay clinically
to validate or verify the
test and the requirements are more
stringent when an assay is considered
laboratory developed
at this time when we were planning our
studies
we made a choice that i'm not sure was
the right choice but we made it
nonetheless and we decided that we would
offer these tests
as a multiplex so anaplasma lovisia and
erlichia
as well as individual singleplex assays
looking back i'm not sure that's the
right decision
but it was the decision we made at the
time so we were going to
validate the multiplex as well as the
singleplex
individually something that
fortunately we started thinking about
early
was samples so obviously you need
samples to perform
the validation studies especially the
accuracy part
and even though the cap standard says
that you can
spike your samples
i just didn't feel like spiking samples
with a synthetic gene
was really a great way to test an assay
i thought i wanted to get my hands on
hands on some really true clinical
samples but it was winter
and that was difficult um i
i reached out to all the large reference
labs i asked them if we could purchase
samples
and that didn't work out um i had been
at dia soren's talk
similar to this in person that year and
i reached out to the speakers of that
talk that they didn't have any samples
yet either
so i was kind of fortunate in that i
used to work like i said
at a at a lab that studied tick-borne
diseases
and i was able to travel to that lab and
beg my kind friends
to raid their freezers for me and i was
able to come up with
a decent amount of anaplasma
babesia and a little bit of
erlichia samples that were truly from
patients
to round out the studies i did wind up
spiking samples
i tried to spike the samples
with extracted nucleic acid from the
true clinical specimens that we had as
opposed to
with synthetic genes because i just
thought that was a better
study but i will admit that for
likia it was tough for me to to find the
positives
being in the northeast it's not super
prevalent
and i did wind up spiking a few samples
with the synthetic gene for erlichia
but for the accuracy part of our
validation studies we wound up using 56
samples
39 of those were positive and 17
of those were negative
and you can see we got pretty good
results so when i make
these type of tables for a multiplex
assay
i always make sure that i include the
results from all the targets
in the table meaning in a multiplex for
anaplasma ibiza and erlichia
an anaplasma positive sample is also
negative
for bobesia and erlichia and a negative
sample is negative for all three
analytes
so i include all of that in in the table
i also break the tables down
by by analyte but what's shown here is
a table that represents the results for
all samples and all
analytes in the accuracy portion of our
study
and this is specific for the multiplex
assay so we wound up with
a 97.4 percent
sensitivity and a specificity of a
hundred percent
we did miss one spiked babesia sample
it tested negative in the multiplex pcr
but positive
in the singleplex when we repeated it in
the multiplex it was positive with a ct
of 34
but you know we had spiked it very close
to the limit of detection i had done the
spiking after i completed the limited
detection studies
so i think that was probably the issue
there
we thought about increasing the number
of replicates
um we performed
to really examine the lod more
thoroughly but but we didn't do it so we
just
you know we accepted that we missed one
sample
so i didn't show the data but we also
performed lod studies and we
looked at cross reactivity and
interferences
and things like that so for the lod
studies
we used the synthetic material we spiked
it
into whole blood at known concentrations
and then we made 10-fold dilutions
and once we landed on what we thought
would be the lod we tested that
concentration repeatedly
for most analytes in the singleplex and
the multiplex assay
the lod came out to be the same
so across the board we saw the lod come
out to be 18 gene copies per test which
we thought was pretty good
there was one exception to that and it
was for babisia
reverse of what we saw in the accuracy
studies actually so in the babesia
singleplex
assay we wound up missing a replica so
the lod was determined to be
180 gene copies per test
and you know we were we were okay with
that
so we also performed reproducibility and
precision studies where we repeatedly
tested the same samples
in the same run as well as in different
runs with different operators and we
got excellent results in those study for
our positive control
we wound up using the synthetic genes
all three spikes into one sample
and to this day i'm amazed at how steady
the ct of that was over time i mean over
an entire year
the ct of our positive control material
hardly ever moved
it was incredibly consistent
so to look at cross reactivity
we tested samples containing common
blood-borne pathogens
and we tried to focus on similar
pathogens if we could i had gotten a
handful
of nice samples from the lab whose
freezer i rated
including some plasmodium positive
samples so that was nice to be able to
include that
i know that some places like new york
have special requirements in terms of
what they want to see
included but that's really a facility
specific decision
and we just did the best that we could
with gathering
you know similar organisms and common
bloodborne pathogens for those studies
we did somewhat rely on an in-silico
analysis to look at things like
frenzicella
tularentis things like that
we also spiked samples known to contain
potential pcr inhibitors
for interference studies so we spiked
severely
lypic and enteric blood
and we got great results we also
made simulated samples that contained
kind of high-end concentrations of
various over-the-counter medications
and this was something i had seen in
commercial
fda 510k studies and i thought that was
relevant and achievable for
us and you know everything really looked
great our validation went well
and we were pretty comfortable moving
forward with the assay
so we did that in may
of 2019 and so what i'm showing you here
is our in-house testing data
from june 2019 through december
of 2019 and interestingly our volume
almost doubled from the year before so
thank goodness we brought it online
right it would have cost over a million
dollars to send out all this testing
so we were pretty quickly able to save a
significant amount of money by bringing
this up
this in-house and of course we were
also able to significantly reduce the
turnaround time
for our patients and providers
at first the turnaround time decrease
was
by a couple of days two to three days on
average
is how we were able to reduce it so
instead of spending you know over a
million dollars we spent about 150 000
on reagents and reduced that turnaround
time it was great
in terms of percent positivity um
our positivity went up slightly for
anaplasma
but stayed in the three-ish range i
think it went up to like 3.9 percent
and our obesia positivity went up
from point five to one percent as well
um
the number of the busiest smears we
processed
uh was reduced from 88 to 58
and you know you can see we're still
following positive patients
for percent peristemia with our blood
smears it's just something our providers
really like
and we still saw no earlier
we did have small numbers of requests to
test two analytes or even one analyte in
the assay
and pretty quickly
we realized that that you know wasn't
something that
worked well for us so
um i mentioned it before that i didn't
think
validating the test both ways uh was a
great decision
and part of the reason why is you know
it just didn't make sense it was
it was cumbersome to keep up with which
sample needed which analyte and so
pretty quickly
even when a single analyte was ordered
we ran the
test as a multiplex test
and so of course we ran into the
situation where an analyte that wasn't
ordered turned up positive on our test
and in those instances we would just you
know
let the let the provider know that we
really felt strongly they should order
testing for
whatever analyte was positive and then
we would release
that result as well
after bringing the test in house we were
able to offer our providers some
education
and we were over time able to decrease
the serologic testing that got ordered i
think they felt more comfortable with
our turnaround time so they weren't
ordering serology
as often and it's not shown here but we
were able to reduce the amount of
repetitive and duplicate testing that
occurred
in our population so our physicians were
happy
we were happy we really had a had a good
experience bringing it on
that said we did run into a few
challenges some things were really very
nice
um for example our small team
used to be somewhat frustrated that they
would get so busy in the winter with flu
testing and in the summer
they would feel somewhat bored like i
don't have enough to do
and when i got the job i thought well
i'll give you guys something to do and
so this balanced out fluid testing quite
nicely
and it kept us busy throughout the year
this is all pre-covered obviously
and because tick testing was somewhat
seasonal we were able to get it on a
seasonal testing schedule
meaning meaning
we are
um we run it every day during the tick
season and then we were running it less
frequently
in the off season
and that worked well for us as well so
we did notice that our extraction
platform
was kind of hammering us we could only
extract 24 samples at a time
and during the heavy season it was
nothing to get 24 or 48
samples in a day and it's relatively
time consuming to set up
one of those extraction runs and the
best that we could get out would be two
runs in one day
so we were really limited by our
extraction platform in terms of
throughput and that was something that
we plan to look into further in the
future
and i already brought it up but the
multiplex versus the mix and match
ordering
quickly kind of turned into an issue for
us it just wasn't um
you know it wasn't a very smart way to
go and again depending on your
physicians
and how they feel about being able to
you know
clinically decide when somebody has
babisia versus anaplasma
you may not have much of a choice they
may demand that you have them
you know offered singly but for us
actually running the singleplex assays
did not
make a lot of sense financially or
workflow wise
so that was something you know we would
revisit if we were starting
from scratch the other
issue that we had was the small volume
pipe heading
so these assays rely on a very small
volume of primer and probe mixing 0.2
microliters some of that is addressed
by batching your runs
in labs i had worked in previously we
had set up excel
files where you just plug in the number
of samples that you have to run that day
and a master mix formula is kind of
created
for you and i had previously worked with
a 10
excess volume so that is where we
started
i think balancing a master mix shortage
and
waste is one of the larger challenges
when you're doing assays that have kind
of small
volumes meaning when you prepare your
master mix
and you're pipetting these tiny volumes
there's nothing worse than
getting to your 24th sample and not
having enough master mix for that sample
so like i said we initially addressed it
by always making about 10 percent extra
and once we got more comfortable
and especially you know certain
employees
they would reduce that to five percent
excess but i'll say i think we always
made an excess
and because we were saving so much money
it really
uh it didn't make that much difference
it was it was just
something that made us more comfortable
something that made the work flow more
smoothly so
it is what we did
another thing was that pretty quickly
everybody was begging me to purchase a
repeater pipettor for dispensing that
five microliter
master mix into these wells
and we did that we purchased a repeater
pipettor
and i think once i did that everybody
was pretty happy
one other thing we fine-tuned was we
decided that we would mix the primers
and make kind of primer mix aliquots
store them frozen that was just a
workflow
solution that we came up with that that
worked well for us
so like i said i think we were very
happy with the assay
and feeling good about it our providers
were very happy
and i have a couple of cases in here
that
illustrate why the providers were so
happy
with us so this first case
illustrates two things one of them being
that our rapid
turnaround time really helps them get
patients on the correct therapy quickly
so this is the case from mid to late
july
when pick season's in full swing a
six-year-old girl came in with a fever
kind of non-specific headache body ache
things like that
she was vomiting and she had a
new onset of a periorbital rash
her labs indicated that she had
thrombocytopenia
and pretty quickly on they ordered blood
and urine culture's
chest x-ray and because her mother
mentioned it that she had a tick bite a
couple weeks earlier
they ordered a pick pcr and lime
serology
at the time they gave her acetaminophen
and zofran
and fluids because i think she was
relatively dehydrated when she got in
so same day we were able to turn around
pcr positive results
for babesia and she was started on
etobicone and azithromycin pretty
quickly
and she was admitted i think probably
because of her age and dehydration they
chose to admit her
and the next day typical to our
providers they ordered a
blood smear to follow her percent
peristemia
but it was negative
and that's something that we commonly
saw and
i put this case in here because i think
it's something that you know if you
offer both a molecular test for babesia
and a blood smear you may have to get
used to explaining when one is positive
and the other isn't it was something
that we had to get used to explaining
and i believe it was
samples that had cts above 27
were rarely positive by by smear and so
we were
you know very quickly comfortable
explaining that the pcr is more
sensitive than the
blood smear and when the ct is that high
particularly it's not uncommon not to
see the organism in the smear
but this patient was discharged home the
next day and
all was well
all right so this next case i think is
really interesting because this is you
know during prime time covid
this was in may um a 70
71 year old man showed up at the covid
mobile assessment site
and he really sounds like he has coveted
right he has a two to three day history
of fever chills
cough muscle aches runny nose and
shortness of breath
i mean sound voice code right
he had pre-existing afib and
he had some tachycardia and i think
because of those cardiac issues
they sent him to our emergency
department
at about 1pm and you know i'm proud of
the fact that the same day
pretty quickly thereafter we were able
to
get him a negative coveted pcr test
probably on the dsorum platform actually
because same day turnaround time we were
using the dsr and kova tests for at the
time
so his other labs if you looked in the
charts it said he had a normal white
blood cell count he had mild
thrombocytopenia
but if you look at the results he really
also had some mild leukopenia
as well um
so his initial therapy was uh
nothing he was discharged with the
probable
viral illness i'm guessing that they
gave him the talk you know
your copa test may be falsely negative
if things get worse come back tomorrow
but fortunately for
this guy before he was discharged he
said well wait a minute
i had a tick bite i had a tick bite a
couple weeks ago
what if that's my problem
so they ordered to take pcr
and the next day it came back positive
for anaplasma
and our providers contacted him asked
him to return
and i think when they called him he said
you know i was going to return anyway
because my symptoms have progressed and
they're worse
so he was admitted and this time he had
kind of severe thrombocytopenia
still mild leukopenia and he was
started on iv doxycycline and discharged
a few days later
i think he had a like a somewhat
extended stay
but primarily due to his cardiac issues
but
i thought that case was really
interesting because if you were
presenting his symptoms to me
you know in prime covered time i would
have thought he had covered as well
all right so the last case is
a 64 year old woman who arrived in our
emergency department via an ambulance
she had a one week history of a fever
that came and went some body and
headaches as well as painful urination
her lfts were slightly elevated and she
had some leukopenia
so initially this patient was treated
with zosin and vancomycin
i think probably because her urinary
symptoms
and she came in
pretty late in the evening by the
ambulance and so the next day they
ordered a battery of tests including
the tick pcr you know i think
one thing that these cases illustrate is
we're not going to run the test if it's
not ordered right so your providers have
to be pretty tuned in to what's going on
in your patient population and have to
think
to order these tests in a couple of
these cases it was the patient
themselves that
pushed ordering the test but in this
case
you know the providers ordered it on
their own and you can also notice
that they ordered both the pick pcr and
the anaplasma interleukin serologies
so in our defense this was actually a
case
from 2019 so we had only been
performing the test in-house for
something like seven weeks at the time
and we hadn't really been able to
educate people that you know you might
as well order the tick pcr wait for the
results before you
um order the serologies which are gonna
are gonna take longer and may be
unnecessary at the end of the day
but regardless they ordered them all and
same day her test came back pcr-positive
for anaplasma
eventually her serology came back as
negative for anaplasma
and she received a full course of
doxycycline and was discharged a couple
days later
another reason i chose to include this
case is because this patient was given
the wrong
medication at the start of her
stay and that wasn't something that we
saw commonly but it was something that
we saw on occasion
and she had anaphasma but it happened
more frequently when a patient had
babisia
and they were started on some type of
antibiotic that wouldn't
address libya
so at the end of 2019 we were feeling
really good
we had recognized a pretty significant
cost savings we had saved over a million
dollars
we had significantly decreased the
turnaround time and time to appropriate
therapy for our patients
and we were able to focus on some
stewardship efforts
including reducing duplicate orders
reducing redundant orders
and reducing the amount of smears that
we
performed we found those to be kind of
labor intensive
we also you know from my standpoint i
had more control
over our data it's easy for me to
manipulate
and analyze data when it is in my own
limb system so at the end of 2019
we said we were going to optimize a
panel
uh for what's going on regionally in our
area and by that i mean
i was interested in looking at borrelia
miami
i think that we must have more of that
than we know
and i think it was it was something i
was very interested in
we were also interested in looking at an
alternative extraction platform
to increase our throughput being held to
24 samples
a run was you know not great
for us but
then 2020 happens and
all of our plans were basically
destroyed
we learned some important lessons
in 2020
we are at the mercy of our supply chains
right
so unfortunately we learned that really
quickly
um in april we found out that we were
not going to be able to get our easy mag
reagents anymore
because we were not using them for cova
testing um
you know i begged i pleaded but i
couldn't get an allocation
and to be quite honest with you i was
begging and breathing for
uh covet tests and it was tiring so
we had to accept that we weren't going
to be able to
get these reagents and the other thing
that we also had to accept is that we
were completely
completely unprepared to handle our
covet testing volume
you know i used to think the tickborne
pcr was
a high volume test in our molecular
section
i think only std testing and flu testing
had higher numbers
and we used to do maybe 3 500 of these
take pcrs a year
it's nothing for us to do 3 500 code
pcrs in a week
and i think if we had opened it up we
could have done that many in a day
so our staff were just completely
overwhelmed
we had to rapidly expand i think we
doubled the number
of dsorn instruments we had in our lab
doubled some of our other platforms as
well
we had to expand our molecular staff
into the you know evening shift
and it was just it was really
overwhelming and so the end result of
that was we had to resume send outs
in june of 2020 which is really sad
because we were really proud when we
brought this on
and had saved so much turnaround time
and money
so since we have started sending it out
in june of 2020 we've sent out 2100
tests and that's about one third decline
in the volume we've had prior to covid
you know at that level of testing it's
cost us over
half a million dollars to send those
tests out and importantly
it is added five days to the turnaround
time
of these tests and i don't say that to
criticize any of the large reference
labs thank goodness for them right if it
wasn't for them we wouldn't be able to
do it and i know that they were
challenged by kova just as much as we
have been but five days is a big deal
and that is what we have added
turnaround time since we've had to send
it out
so our future goals are to bring this
testing back in house
i don't know about you guys but we're
starting to feel like we're at a
sustainable level with this coveted
testing
even though it's a crazy level it's
sustainable
and we do plan to make this the first
test that we bring back
but we're also looking at higher
throughput extraction platforms
so we don't have that limitation of the
24 samples
and there may be some options there
because some labs we work closely with
you know rapidly expanded to the covid
and they may have some extraction
platforms that we can
get at a deal basically so that is my
last
slide i'd like to thank you for your
attention and i will take
any questions that you might have
thank you sarah for your informative
presentation we will now start the live
q a portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for
okay let's get started our first
question is
do you see a specific population being
tested within your region e.g men versus
women
children versus adults etc
um well that's an interesting question i
think you know historically there might
have been the notion that
men um would be more inclined to get
these types of diseases
because you know historically maybe they
were considered to be
outside more and doing these things more
but i don't subscribe to that notion at
all i think
women are just as likely to be hiking
fishing and
outside gardening and getting pics so in
terms
of gender no we do not
see much of a difference between testing
men
and women
in terms of age
when i was looking at the data i
happened to see that we had tested
a 102 year old patient
with our pcr and that led me to look at
the range of ages
that we had tested and it may not be
surprising we don't really test babies
babies aren't walking around
picking up ticks people usually you know
keep them out of harm's way in that
respect but once a kid starts walking
we do start testing that population so
certainly we test more adults
um but we also test children and i think
like i said in terms of gender it's
pretty evenly split between men
and women
wow that's quite the age range thank you
sarah and our next question
ticks are nature's perfect vehicle for
transmitting microbes did you encounter
any co-infections
through your validation and also is
under recognition of co-infections a
reason that some patients do not get
better
following their initial diagnosis and
treatment for lyme disease
um so in terms of co-infections during
our validation like i
explained it was really difficult to get
real clinical samples
for our validation studies and so the
samples that we tested
during that time were not from patients
with co-infections
that said i did spike some samples
so that we would ensure that we were
looking
at detecting multiple analytes in the
assay
so i created some confections and we did
test
samples that way
in looking back through
the data when we were testing i don't
believe that we ever
detected anaplasma and babies together
and i i know that we didn't detect or
look in combination with anything else
either because we didn't detect any or
like yeah
but i am certain that we detected a ton
of co-infections
with lyme we definitely saw
lime and vibesia we definitely saw a
lime in anaplasma
and it was not that uncommon in our
patient population
it was kind of tricky to know when that
was going on because it's two different
testing platforms but we had some lime
studies that we were doing that kind of
led us to look so i know it happened
um and the second part of the question
uh
are co-infections a reason why patients
don't get better
after treatment for lyme you know
i think primarily not i think when
patients
don't get better following lyme a lot of
times it
is probably due to some you know some
type of autoimmune
pathology but that said i think that a
provider is always going to have to
consider a co-infection and ensure that
the co-infections have been ruled out
because certainly
it can be a reason why patients don't
get better
i think i gave the similar talk last
year and one of the cases i included
was actually a elderly man who
had lyme disease and was being treated
for lyme disease
but he wound up you know unresponsive on
the floor
and the reason for that was because he
had babisia so it can be a reason but i
don't think it
is the primary reason
but definitely needs to be ruled out
wow thank you sarah we have another
question coming in
how many days would you expect to find
pcr positive results in the blood
following tick exposure for these
infections
so following tick exposure for the
infections
i i would think it it's a couple of days
you know even a week or more before
we're going to see
the tcr as
positive definitely a couple of a couple
of days how long would that positivity
last
i think depends largely on the
patient and the immune status of the
patient
and whether they are going to be treated
but i will say in the context of babesia
in the very beginning when we had
patients who
became babisia positive by pcr and then
their providers tried to follow their
percent parasiteemia
with the blood smears in the very
beginning i think people were getting
frustrated when they were negative
and were reordering the pic pcr
and you know while we did not charge the
patient sometimes we didn't run those
samples because we were somewhat curious
how long it would last
and um it lasted a lot longer
than you might expect you weren't seeing
the p the
the blood smears positive but for a few
weeks
in the very sick patients we were seeing
babesia positivity in the pcr even with
treatment
thank you sarah we've got time for one
more question
do you think these co-infections are
more likely to occur
if the lyme disease's causative agent is
also present
um i mean i do i think statistically
speaking
uh borrelia burgdorferi is present in
more
of our ticks and if a patient
has lyme disease on one hand you know
they are frequenting tick heavy areas or
areas that have ticks
they're more likely to encounter a tick
that has
lime and something else and you know the
ticks that spread lime
are notorious for harboring multiple uh
pathogens
so you know um if a co-infection is
going to be detected in the patient
i would say it's most likely to be
detected in the patient that
has lyme disease
all right thank you so much sarah do you
have any final comments for our audience
today
i don't i thank you for your attention
and uh good luck with everything that's
going on
crazy time right it is for sure
well thank you again sarah for your time
today and for your important research
we would also like to thank labruz and
our sponsor theosorin molecular for
underwriting today's educational webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by the speaker
via the contact information you provided
at the time of registration
this webcast can be viewed on demand lab
roots will alert you via email when it's
available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye